hello everyone my name is ishan from
simply learn
and today we will learn about pmp
certification today we will discuss
about pmp certification in detail
let's first have a look at all the
topics we will cover we will begin with
what is pmp
then we will check top 10 reasons to get
pmp certified
followed by the basics of pmp then after
we know the pmp basic concepts we will
check who can get the certification
and pattern for the pmp exam then we
will learn about the pmbok guide which
is an integral part to prepare for the
pmp exam finally
we will see the cost and the validity of
the certification so without any further
ado
let's begin with what is pmp pmp a
project management professional is the
world's most renowned project management
certification
for project managers this certification
is provided by the project management
institute
now when we know what is project
management professional or pmp
certification
let's have a look at some reasons why
you should get pmp certified today i
will give you top 10 reasons to take pmp
certification pmp certification
helps you become a better project
manager the process that helps us
acquire the certification
goes to several phases like gaining
project management experience and
passing the pmp exam which helps you in
bringing sanity to the project manager
the process helps project managers to
learn different industry trends have
practical knowledge and several other
project management constraints
the second reason that we have is
project management certification
makes our resume more valuable as we
have discussed earlier that pmp
certification is the most renowned
project management certification so
having it on the resume will definitely
help the interviewer recognize our
skills there are companies that only
accept project managers who are pmp
certified pmp certification not only
helps in switching the job or finding a
new one
it helps in progressing in the current
company as well
the third reason that we have is it
provides more job opportunities
when one acquires the pmp certification
it proves that one has expertise in
completing the project
effectively and efficiently so the
certification increases the trust factor
of the interviewer in you and increases
your probability of getting that job
the fourth reason that we have is salary
hikes pmp certified project manager is
one of the highest paid jobs around the
globe and this trend will continue to
grow
the global survey by the project
management institute shows that pmp
certified project managers tend to get
20
more salary than the non-certified
project managers the next reason that we
have is
pmp certification validates your
dedication to the job
the certification requires several
months of training
it requires several hours of project
management experience and exposure
this experience and exposure explains
the seriousness of a project manager
towards its career path
then sixth we have is pmp certification
is globally acknowledged pmp
certification is the most
renowned certification all over the
world it helps project managers to be a
part of different types of industries
all over the globe pmp certification is
the most renowned certification all over
the world project managers who are pmp
certified may get jobs in different
types of industries all over the world
pmp certification
not only provides theoretical knowledge
but also helps in gaining practical
knowledge which further helps in
increasing the confidence of a project
manager the next reason that we have is
better project performance pmp certified
project managers tend to deliver better
projects than the non-pmp certified
project
managers this is because pmp certified
project managers are well aware of 5
process groups 10 knowledge areas and 49
processors which helps them have a clear
picture of different aspects
involved in a project the 8th reason
that we have is
it increases your networking
opportunities there are several
communities that one becomes a part of
when they sign up as a pmi member
these communities have meetings
regarding new job opportunities and this
helps in having a professional network
the ninth reason that we have is job
security
job security is a major reason that a
professional thinks of before opting for
a particular profession today
in the world of recession where
companies are drowning the demand for
pmp certified project managers goes on
increasing
the last and the 10th reason we have is
expertise in practical application
when one appears for a pmp exam they
need extensive preparation
they need to have thorough knowledge of
process groups and knowledge areas which
help them develop
several essential skills and move ahead
in their career now
as we move further we will look into the
pmp basic concepts the pmp basic
concepts are the five project management
steps
these project management steps start
from the day we begin our project to the
day we end our project they begin from
initiation to closure the first step
that we have is
initiation planning execution monitoring
and controlling
and closure now let's have a look at
each of them in detail
the first step we have is initiation
initiation
involves defining the project scope this
is the step where we explain
what our project will have for whom we
are making that project it helps us
to identify our stakeholders who all
will be the part of that project and
determine the project feasibility
after this step of initiation when we
have decided the scope of our project
the second step that comes is planning
in the planning phase we define a flow
to all the activities of our project we
define this flow keeping in mind all the
constraints of a project
like time resources and risk after we
have defined the flow of these processes
it is time for us to look at the
execution in the execution phase we
evaluate the plan and the sequence of
the tasks we have made we finally put
the plan in action
and the project tends to start after the
project building has started and the
process of execution has started it is
time for the monitoring and the
controlling phase
in monitoring and controlling phase the
progress of the project is tracked
and important steps for quality
assurance are taken in monitoring and
controlling phase the work being done
is compared with the work as defined in
the project plan in this phase the
progress of the project is tracked and
important steps for quality assurance
are taken
finally we have the closure step in this
step the deliverables are delivered to
the client the documentation of all that
took place
during the project life cycle is done
and project is fully evaluated
now when we have seen reasons for
getting pmp certified and we know the
basic concepts of pmp it is time for us
to know who can get pmp certified for
getting pmp certified there can be two
cases
the first case says you must have a
secondary degree a secondary degree
means high school diploma or an
associate degree or a degree that is
globally equivalent to all of these
then you need to have 7 500 hours of
leading and directing projects and 3 500
hours of project management education
there can be two cases first case can be
you must have a secondary degree that
means a high school diploma associates
degree or the global equivalent degree
then you must have 7 500 hours of
project management experience
and 35 hours of education in project
management
the second case can be you must have a
four-year degree
along with 4 500 hours of project
management experience and 35 hours of
education in project management
now when we know who can get pmp
certified we will see the pmp exam
pattern the exam comprises of 200
questions
out of which 175 questions are used for
evaluation one can answer these
questions
if they have thorough knowledge of 5
process groups and 10 knowledge areas
the time provided to complete the exam
is 4 hours the questions that are asked
are of different types the most common
type being
formula based situation based and
knowledge based now when we have
discussed about the exam pattern
discussing about the pmbok guide becomes
very important so the next topic that we
have is
pmbok guide pmbok guide or project
management body of knowledge is a book
that comprises of several processes and
different terminologies needed to crack
the pmp exam
the whole syllabus of pmp exam is
covered in the pmbok guide by the
project management and 10 knowledge
areas
apart from this there are 49 processes
that are divided amongst 5 process
groups 10 knowledge areas
finally let's have a look at the cost
and validity of the pmp certification
when we talk about the cost of the
certification there can be two cases the
first case can be if we are not a member
of project management institute the exam
fees is 555 us dollars
the second case can be if we are a
member of project management institute
the exam fees is 405 u.s dollars if we
talk about the validity of the
certification a certificate is valid for
a period of three years
after every three years the certificate
needs to be renewed to renew the
certificate one needs to furnish a proof
of 60 pdus or professional development
units
after so much information that thanks
john for his time and promises to take
the pmp certification at the shortest
notice
now let's have a look at the salary
trends of a pmp certified project
manager and a sample resume if we
consider the salary of a non-pmp
certified project manager it is
approximately
91 000 while if we consider the salary
of a pmp certified project manager it is
approximately
one hundred eleven thousand dollars
which is approximately
twenty percent higher than the
non-certified project managers salary
now let's have a look at the resume of a
pmp certified project manager
if you are somebody with pmp
certification and looking for a project
manager or a senior project manager role
your resume should look something like
this
the summary in the beginning would
include how much experience you have and
anything that supports your claim of
being a project manager
like here james brown has written he has
more than 10 years of experience
with generating and building projects
then when you talk about your experience
you should put something that emphasizes
on the responsibilities that you had
your area of expertise put something
that shows your skill set for the
desired post and also something that you
learn from your former job role this
shows that you have command over your
work and also the determination to skill
and upskill yourself
like here james brown has three years of
experience as an assistant manager
training new associates and then more
than three years of experience as a
project manager where he not only led
projects but also learned new project
management tools like trello and
primavera
after this add relevant information
regarding your education your resume
must include skills that you have or you
have gained in your years of experience
like here james brown has divided his
skills into two parts where he has
written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included a
skill of agile and quality assurance
software
as well as he has his knowledge of
different project management tools then
putting your certifications play a major
role this proves
that you are up to date and updated with
current market trends james brown
has his certifications in c and java and
more importantly he has his project
management certification project
management professional and with that we
have reached the end of this video i
hope you guys found it informative and
helpful thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here